[Music]
when you think of the world's culinary
capital New York and Paris may come to
mind but the tiny town of Yountville
California also has a place on the map
with a whole constellation of Michelin
stars within just a few blocks and it is
thanks largely to one man legendary chef
Thomas Keller on this special edition of
the dish Jamie wax brings us his story
Jamie good morning good morning Dana
Thomas Keller had humble beginnings in
the food business he first worked as a
dishwasher in a Florida restaurant
managed by his mother years later he
found himself struggling to make his
mark when he happened upon the French
Laundry he took it over and made it his
own and it would make Keller a food
world's superstar and turn Yountville
into a world-class destination for
dining can you believe that it's been 25
years of the French Laundry under your
leadership I look back at the 25 years
and it seems like a blink of an eye in
that blink of an eye
Thomas Keller turned this Napa Valley
restaurant into a culinary landmark
attracting flocks of people to this
small town for the meal of a lifetime
what's the most important critical
feedback that you listen to
it's the feedback that comes from us
very seldom are we totally happy with
any one service we could do a hundred
guests tonight and they'll be one thing
that we missed and that's the one thing
we focus on I look at our profession as
a sports franchise we're a baseball team
and so every day whether we win or lose
the night before we're able to come back
and do it again every time we serve a
dish we have the opportunity to the next
time we serve the dish to make it even
better Keller's work ethic is the
foundation at each of his 15 restaurants
and bakeries and it helped him become
the first American chef to earn three
Michelin stars for per se in New York
who currently holds seven michelin stars
how important is that system in that
award to you we never ever thought that
mission would come to the United States
so when they announced that they were we
were all very excited of course but none
of us ever thought that we would receive
the highest accolade that mission could
give which is the three stars if you
receive three Michelin stars today it's
a great thing
but the burden of responsibility has now
become that much heavier going forward
and every year we think about that every
day we think about that making sure that
we are responsible to those stars
Keller's expectations are in plain sight
in the French Laundry state-of-the-art
kitchen balance a sense of urgency with
thinness I'm here with you in the
kitchen in California and we're watching
your team at stay in New York
hi guys it all begins with respect for
the ingredients and the French laundries
ingredients couldn't be fresher many of
them grow across the street this is
celtuce our Chinese lettuce and it has a
nutty flavor almost like a artichoke and
so you eat the base of that as well as
the leaves as well as the leaves
Erin Kiefer is the head gardener
responsible for thousands of pounds of
produce weekly he brings the goods to
executive sous-chef Elliot Bell the
celtuce were doing a salad so we're
doing that with some Satsuma mandarins
and
this kitchen has been called one of the
greatest cooking spaces in America it
recently underwent a 10 million dollar
renovation it's something Keller never
could have imagined when he bought the
restaurant in 1994 I was on my last legs
I had just had a dismal time in Los
Angeles I'd lost my restaurant in New
York this was it for me and to see
what's happened here in this restaurant
and how its influenced so many other
things in our community and in our state
and in our country is something that is
I'm extremely proud and blessed I mean
you could not have a more charming
setting than this town
Keller took a walk with us down
Washington Street home to five of his
restaurants including who's Sean this
feels like I'm in Paris right now once I
walk in that's where we're trying to
achieve and his newest venture to the
surprise of many a casual Mexican eatery
and again we're in a completely
different vibe right helmed by Chef
Kalin Ulrich true so Kalin JB what does
it mean to you as a 27 year old chef to
have the stamp of approval and
partnership of Thomas Keller I'm very
humbled I'm very grateful for it he's
giving me the keys and he's telling me
grab the steering wheel
here's the menu do what's authentic do
what you want to do here you'll find
elevated street food like these tacos al
pastor fresh made of the all of the
Urraco from the coast of oaxaca speak
you eat in Mexico I mean I'm gonna say
that's the best taco ever ate in my life
I'm not gonna eat a better taco today
I'm done or Pescados around the idol
verde branzino cooked on a woodfired
grill and brushed with adobo Cheers
cheers to you
hmm absolutely spectacular Thomas
Keller's star power has drawn
high-profile chefs to Yountville like
Adam Perry Lang Thomas Keller really
paved the way for so many us chefs not
only graduating his kitchen but people
that have been marred and I'm one of
those who admired Thomas first so so
long and just to have the opportunity to
be here and give my form of expression
in my form of cooking through steak and
creating a neighborhood Steakhouse
that's not only just for tourists but
for locals as well it was a big deal for
me and that's really why I went for it
the so-called master of meat brought his
signature dish to Napa from his
Hollywood Steakhouse APL and you're
known for the tomahawk steak tell ya
about that yeah that's it this that's
this right over here this is aged for
about a hundred days yeah it's a
specialty of just one of my favorite
things to cook that will be gone I mean
the bark on that yeah thank you I know
the terminology but it's juicy and
tender with its magic when you can get
both of those appreciate that for fine
dining there's no place quite like
Yountville a gourmet destination
inspired by Thomas Keller the chef who
dared to take a risk
humbled and broken 25 years ago where do
you see yourself 25 years from now
hopefully on a golf course yeah
restaurants are part of my life they've
always been part of my life they think
they'll always continue to be part of my
life in one way or another no longer can
I do what the young chef the parties do
in the restaurant alarm could I do with
the sous chefs do or even the chef de
cuisine but I'm proud to say that
they're better than I am
and that's what continues to motivate me
is that every generation is gonna be
better than the generation before
because that generation gave them the
opportunities gave them the tools gave
them the training so I'm confident that
even if I'm on a golf course
that what's happening here the French
shocking will continue to represent the
level of standards that we have
established in this restaurant
25 years ago on a golf course of the
tomahawk we want a tomahawk right I know
but obviously we left very inspired and
full it was a really really great trip
and you said the best Mexican food you
ever had I I think that Chef Kalin
Ulrich trilling is just really making
magic it's very authentic he comes from
a family of teachers and chefs in Oaxaca
he's a very special that's saying some
all of it and you know you talk about
Thomas Keller success but I never heard
the story of his failures before he
found out about that quite it's all
about that that's where it begins Thank
You Jaime waxen
you